is
[Music]
[Music]
federal law prohibits filming of
endangered falcons except for
educational purposes
to avoid federal crimes and maximum
penalty of up to five years in prison
the following comedy sketch has been
edited in post-production to be
educational viewer discretion is advised
oh pretty bird you're pretty cool oh
[ __ ] it's okay it's okay you pretty
burnt
here what the hell are you doing
this is our it's our falcon
crowdershop.com mascot i'm gonna teach
her how to hunt and you can only think
about falconing
actually it's falconry which
historically was a popular sport and
status symbol among
the nobles of medieval europe and japan
where it's called takaguri
falconry has been around forever and may
have even been started in mesopotamia
[Music]
he's got a
look he's got a hysterical little helmet
with the
spear
good question stephen the falcons hood
used during the phase of its acclimating
to humans which is referred to as the
manning process
is used to keep the raptor
in a calm state both in early parts of
its training and throughout its life
[Music]
you think we can get it to attack
brendan
[Music]
do you want to attack brendan
yes
[Music]
falcons aren't naturally human
aggressive orchestra will do well
starting with
chicken hearts livers then switching to
other meats like sparrows other small
birds
ducks
ducks and pigeons
then move on to mice and insects so
remember if you see a falcon in the wild
it's more afraid of you
than you are of him
to her but yeah
falcons may be badass but not as badass
as merchandise which you can get at
crowdershop.com
[Music]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
hmm
wonderful sip it feels good
on my throat too we have some people
here in the office uh we have someone
who had the test deposit for the covid
ah that's right and i'm paranoid because
i have a slight headache oh dude as
opposed to last week
we don't know
we started we don't know cherish every
day is what i'm telling you uh we each
have a cross to bear stephen yes that's
true
mild think about it dude mild headache
and low grade fever i can't so into the
grave my life today we're going to we
have a bunch we're going to get to john
oliver a lot of people a lot of you were
asking john oliver did a a whole thing
on voting rights yesterday why it's
racist i didn't feel the need to address
it because we've done an entire change
my mind series on this we've done a
segment however he brought up some uh i
can't say new arguments they're very
pedestrian but he brought up the same
arguments again racist israeli all the
stuff you know voter id so we're going
to do a piece by piece rebuttal we
haven't done one of those in a while no
it's been a little bit and uh we're
going to be talking about uh joe biden
uh you know what's 97 vaccination rate
in this country oh he does yeah you
can't get 97 of americans to do anything
that's true and one thing i want to let
you guys know too with john oliver we
want to with this show be very clear
that all he does is just [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] we want to offer some
solutions right and sometimes that's
it's not necessarily political but how
you can implement these in in your life
because it's really easy to sit back and
complain
it's not so easy to actually do
something about it especially as a brit
yeah well there's just you know they
always the problem with their very
sounds increasingly irritating about a
brit coming here and telling us how to
run our own country because the thing
they always say about americans abroad
is uh you also arrogance using the world
should be this way show me one american
host
i don't know what it is belgium
show me one american host in the uk
who craps all over the parliamentary
system and tell them they would never be
allowed that'd be funny
only we are accepting of uh alleged
alleged we're very social and they say
we're all fat yes eat cucumber
sandwiches is that i don't even think
yeah that they're talking about me
really
he does all right speaking of which
gerald a how are you i am well and i
hate cucumbers for the record really
yeah i do love pickles hate cucumbers
really hate them well pickles just a
cucumber on drugs uh quarterback what's
going on you hate eating them that's
that's true no i just hate them feeling
good none of the kovid no
because you're back you know you he's a
quarter vaccine hesitant i'm very happy
yes
and
dave landa how are you sir i'm good ahoy
hoy hey everyone out there you know dave
landau has a show coming up this friday
october 1st yes if you are in
pennsylvania anywhere in the rust belts
near pittsburgh philly homestead
pennsylvania the tickets are in the
description below uh sometimes people
don't really know where to go and buy
tickets oh yeah support live comedy and
you know what look i don't care what you
do as far as supporting live comedy in
the movie he's one of the best out there
very very funny go for it uh
okay it's roughly the area where hillary
clinton had no idea there was steel
company yes yes yeah exactly you know a
company's out of business you mean yes
yeah okay steelers is the it's not
important but she's just moving in oh
she's one of the steelers huh a vote
allegedly
allegedly election fraud not a thing so
not real not a thing never been a thing
no no no no proof hey dave
it's not a thing
there's no election fraud i know you
think that you've seen some votes i've
seen it up here i've no no nowhere to be
thrown in the trash no stop it
i've got your fault it is election fraud
it's not a thing stop it so uh we have
uh mueller left us on tick tock before
we move on here uh now trying to teach
you know gender reveals people are mad
about that uh gender they call this
gender creative parenting well that's a
made-up name if you've ever heard one
hold on i haven't seen this but i'm
willing to bet it's
let's watch the clip
when our child zoomer was born in 2016
my partner brent and i decided to read
his assassins
we didn't disclose their reproductive
anatomy to people who didn't need to
know we used the gender neutral pronouns
they them there until zoomer could tell
us what pronouns fit best confusing
consumer about bodies gender identity
and expression in an expansive and
inclusive way we wanted to hold space
for the possibility that zoomer could be
intercepted yeah you gave a little
prince valiant haircut that's setting
him up for success protecting them from
experiencing sexism in early childhood
how about being compared to the lord
played with all the toys and got to
experience a childhood free of gender
stereotypes
around zumer's fourth birthday he told
us that he's a boy and that he loves he
him pronouns
also loves boogers and understands that
gender is not binary and that his body i
also love [ __ ] his pants
we call this gender creative parenting
and there's this letter this is what he
wants to do community waiting for you if
you want to learn more see the key there
is this what can i say the woman in the
video i have no idea
z says we call this creative gender
parenting
okay you can call it whatever it's
nothing it's not real it's not a thing
this is the issue but then it'll be a
thing and that'll become a part of the
curriculum we're laughing at how absurd
it is but it's hate speech in certain
places like the uk to speak out against
it my home country in canada pastors
jailed mike ward jailed for an offensive
joke this is the issue creative gender
parenting is not a thing
do you know how i know
hospitals you know the places that
you've short staffed
they have to mark it down
they have to mark down the name zoomer i
know
sitting there going are you sure
all right fine here's your stupid kid
they leave it in the preemie ward like
uh you know uh we're just gonna leave it
unlocked it would be a shame if someone
swapped him and gave him a better life
we have a penis girls have a vagina oh
my god kids right
your kid needs parents not a friend
yeah it's really whatever i want to eat
chocolate all night long oh we gotta let
him do it yeah before we move on comment
if you're a parent yeah i just you know
this is a good i have we have twins and
obviously i know people get harder all
this i understand but with twins you
have to get them on a schedule and if
one of them starts whining 20 minutes
ahead we look look you're fine you're
not going to starve we change your
diaper whine it out and then eventually
we're going to get to a point where oh i
want this no
no it doesn't matter if it is
m m's for dinner or to cut off their
penis the answer is no
but zuma's gonna be a bit of a prick
when he grows up
i'm serious like he's gonna think the
world revolves around him and i get to
experience everything and it's about me
getting to make every choice in life and
it's like oh you're just setting
yourself up for hell as parents zoomer's
going to be like that i don't know if it
was the npr podcast where the host would
switch genders in the show what like no
no i'm not we'll bring this up for mug
club someone to control seriously yeah
in the middle of the show was like oh no
now you're talking to uh now you're
talking to tammy i'm a woman now they're
like
okay danny so you have split
personalities okay yeah that's normal
yeah
okay
so zoomer was born a girl
uh no i think a boy oh and then he
figured out all on his own that he's a
boy i don't know if he was born a boy or
a girl they didn't disclose they didn't
disclose ugh
it is man boy i'm gonna buy my son a
kevlar vest
as soon as my son is old enough he's
getting a beer in one hand and a playboy
in the other i'm not raising san
francisco green kids okay nope no
playboys
yes play boys
fine you're clothed now it will be
i don't know esquire whatever it is
it'll be a picture it'll be a poster of
farrah fawcett yeah yeah it won't be a
swimsuit issue of sports illustrated
with it you know yeah it won't be george
clooney on a bearskin rug though we all
have our weaknesses
so uh you should only say no to so much
i'm but a man i'm weak so
brian got his booster shot yesterday hey
isn't that great setting a great example
he got his booster of the of the trump
vaccine oh yeah uh he said he can return
us to normal but what's key here is what
he says about how many americans need to
be vaccinated to return to normal this
is scary
this week in biden wait if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump then you ain't black how
many americans need to be vaccinated for
us to go back to normal like what is the
total
percentage
to have to be deployed
well i think
look
i think we get
the vast majority like is going on in
some of the
some industries at some schools
97 98
i think we've got awful folks and uh
but i'm not the scientist uh
i think but one thing for sure
a quarter of the country can't go on
vaccines
and that's not continuing to have a
problem i mean if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black for those
listening on audio uh yeah you know what
he did he just said 97 or 98 to go back
to normal can you get 97 or 98 percent
of americans to do anything
they wouldn't show up for free cash
right
they've tried to get free cash for
vaccines yeah that didn't work
yeah they didn't start a lottery the
most racist commercials ever i know
you can win a million dollars why aren't
you vaccinated just put a lottery ticket
at the end of a fishing pole and it was
like hey i want it and then he sees the
needle nah i'm out man it's been funny
for the second he got that shot he just
grabs
we got a bleeder
his ears grow
can you imagine how long he bleeds for
it's gonna be like two days off one shot
he's gonna need to get that that other
pfizer anti-clotting drug hey stock goes
up another 542 here's the thing this is
terrifying 97 we can't have a quarter of
the country actually you can it's called
freedom yeah yeah it is called freedom
and let's just be clear
if you trust your vaccine it shouldn't
affect you if the vaccine does what they
said it was going to do not the moved
goal posts it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter your vaccine works
yeah yeah you only have a two percent
chance of being hospitalized and you
guys say hey it reduces it by uh 10
times getting hospitalized we'll get to
some numbers here because it's a little
bit concerning i don't necessarily know
that that data is reflected
in the
data so
the issue here is it is this is a this
is a terrifying power grab and we'll get
to new york a little bit we're releasing
the military oh my god yeah um
this always starts with something small
and that's why we'll be talking about
john oliver it's something as silly as
seat belt laws
what was that oh you just hit something
uh also by the way even mindfuche said
percent of americans right that was the
number seventy percent for herd immunity
that's a factor that's overlaid a
seventy percent for hurt immunity and uh
this was after of course he mocked rand
paul for the notion of hurt immunity
well he's been right about everything
else yeah
i think i think actually fauci bring
that overlay bring that over he changed
it
oh it's something that's 90 percent i
mean why not go up he said so i thought
i could nudge this up a bit so i went to
80 85 remember rand paul was talking
about her immunity that's unbelievable
with all due respect senator you don't
know what you're talking about really
can kids still catch aids from the
cinnamon toast crunch box
yeah but i love that he's just like 70
and he's like i don't know maybe we
could negotiate i'm like i thought this
was science i didn't think you
negotiated with a virus yeah how about
how about you guys stop you shut up the
shopping mall opens back up and i can go
to a roly-poly at the food court my
point here is it always starts with
something small and we'll progress here
in the show so you start seeing kind of
what's going on uh so there was another
case here cheryl burke i guess
dancing with the stars yesterday we had
a list of uh i don't know two dozen
celebrities who had
uh breakthrough kova despite being
vaccinated she now announced that even
though she's fully vaccinated she has
the covid i warn you the video
uh is
it's it's heart-wrenching
okay guys so
i have really bad news
yeah i am
positive
which means i have kovit
and i just got the news now and i've
been
anticipating
just waiting around for since seven
o'clock this morning he's about to make
the long walk
i just feel like [ __ ] to be quite
honest um
and it's so overwhelming because
it's sunday and this shows tomorrow but
um
yeah
i figured i should let you guys know
since
i've been as open and like a suicide
note overall as i could be here
i just hope i didn't spread it
[Laughter]
for those of you we're talking
with a slight cough and a
and a mild flu that he would take over
the normal flu anecdotal of course total
statistical reality um for most people
particularly young people just to be
very very clear we're at the point come
on can we all acknowledge this is
ridiculous now yeah it's absolutely i
just i just you know i just i saw my la
i saw my life flash before my eyes
before i realized that in my demographic
there's a 0.5 percent in them being
hospitalized okay look at a certain
point you have to toughen up sweetheart
gonna update my will she's acting like
it's yeah an inoperable brain tumor
i just got the worst news it's like you
had to be told you were sick
it's like a kid who you know struggles
and gets up and it's fine like oh you're
bleeding
yeah
but she's uh she's here's the thing
she's vaccinated
uh you know dave must be one of those
those uh those breakthrough cases it's a
pandemic right here it's a pandemic very
rare that's what i said something else
if you've read in uh in other news
pringles is changing their logo
for the first time in 20 years yeah mr
p's new design is
more of an emoji style um
help me hold on
to what we
hate
once our love was strong
and it can't be again
you said it takes two
to make love last
you were right all along
so help me hold on
you're right
all alone
help me hold on
help me
[Music]
uh mr p's new design is uh
more of an emoji style much simpler than
the current logo do you have the
passcode i don't know
yeah that's great i will
yeah well i don't want to do that story
sorry guys no we don't yeah it's okay
dave i uh
touched i know uh this show
october 1st friday uh link is in the
description in pennsylvania go see uh
dave he's a sensitive soul but he's
funny uh also
this show is a podcast you can subscribe
on audio yeah which i think is probably
more appreciated today uh on apple and
spotify all these places and the android
yeah not not itunes not it's just apple
i still remember when it was itunes
boomer i'm a millennial ah dang it uh
and it's a live show monday through
thursday 10 00. eastern best thing you
can do is smash that like button comment
okay
here's a story too
you gotta wait for the smash smash
fish
take it out
like it take it
take it so hey right now hold on one
second before we move on
milly
general milly is on the tv again
but it looks like it looks like dead
general milly it's just it's just normal
general milly
yeah it's just how he looks he put on
makeup no no no like he should just be
rattling some cupboards
shaking the bed post
just say hi what are all his medals for
uh well you know i guess he earned them
something or other but telling
your secrets
this is my snitching badge right here
and this one's for treason
[Laughter]
um all right so look uh this is a few
days ago and i was reading this the bbc
published this article look at the
headline the headline is in covid and
wales a third of positive cases are
unvaccinated oh no wait that's a strange
way to say two-thirds of positive cases
are vaccinated yeah really yes it's they
like to pepper up them wait the vast
majority of cases are vaccinated you say
well did you hear me what i said
and by the way the headline doesn't
really make sense you have to read the
article because
it goes into more detail and it actually
seems like they're the numbers may not
even be accurate in the title it says 45
of cases are among the vaccinated 20
they don't know
okay but 80 of hospitalized patients in
wales are vaccinated what
80
of hospitalized patients
are vaccinated and they'll say well it's
because most of the population is
vaccinated it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
you don't talk about that with measles
mumps rubella you don't if the vaccine
works it doesn't matter if 95 of the
population is vaccinated and they make
up
only 85 percent of the hospitals it
sucks i'm just curious you just said
that one-third were unvaccinated that's
confirmed 20 are kind of in the wind
we're not sure and you're telling me
eighty percent that's what makes a
hospital no eighty percent are in the
hospital with one third unvaccinated so
it doesn't matter if you think your
entire country is almost vaccinated
they're not because one third's not yeah
it doesn't make any sense does not make
any sense of terrorism it's just a very
interesting way this is where you have
to read articles and i'll be working on
a project to hopefully help people with
this and yeah our links are in sources
they're all available in the description
um and look call me on it comment if you
see a source you're like oh that's
probably not the best source or it's not
right it's not the best reference we
have a bibliography every show 40 to 60
links it's just surprising to me i was
reading it yeah first i was like wow i
guess that wait a second no wait that
means that's just a different way of
saying two-thirds 66 percent of people
in wales
are vaccinated who have covet yeah it's
just peppering it up to make it sound
better than it is it's just word play
it's like 81 percent of traffic
fatalities occur when you're stone cold
sober right hold on
there was 95
of the airplane fuel needed to get
leonard skinner to their gig yes yeah 10
of rihanna's face was completely
untouched by chris brown robert wagner
newly single almost the entire cast
of the crow attended the film premiere
almost the entire channel
almost
minus one incident chris benoit was an
amazing husband
the point is it's minus one
that's the lead here
hussein has fully cooperated with the
international community since december
30th 2006. he was great for a while yeah
david carradine dies doing what he loves
he did
most of the time
11 hey hey 11 out of 12 lakers practice
safe sex well what okay that's good yeah
we're on the right track that other it's
just one it's just don't worry about the
world i'm vaccinated
the ambrosia chocolate company uh in
milwaukee says almost all of our
employees are overwhelmingly not
cannibalistic gay necrophages yes ah
we're making we're getting they're
getting better
no dahmer anymore sorry about the
bunnies in the 80s jfk retires early the
point is with these headlines
you need to know how they're trying to
manipulate you one in seven we're still
going six why not one in seven point six
billion people get throat cancer from
going down on catherine zeta-jones one
is seven point six billion that's higher
than odds
that's really just more of an excuse mr
douglas uh some cigars may have been
involved yeah
no no hey by the way no children have
accused michael jackson of uh uh being a
sexual uh uh rapist pedophile since 2009
2009. that is good he's got his 11-year
pin yes he does
[Laughter]
it's on
miley's military jacket yeah he'd walk
into an alcoholic's anonymous i think i
got my nine month opinion what does that
mean i didn't rape a you know kid
i just i just like coors
yeah why not are you the guy
just drink a little wild turkey to drown
out the you know the feeling that my dad
never loved me you uh
i think we're gonna kill you if you're
in this group and make it look like an
accident
oh let me move walk out of here
one-third
wow
that's so awesome all right also wales
you still haven't apologized for that
i'll just tweet later
by the way wales still hasn't apologized
for that [ __ ] in frayser where did that
accent come from that's just i don't
know what it is but you still someone
needs to own it
all right so this is something else i
want to talk about really before we get
to john oliver uh this is
really scary yeah and i want to clarify
again how the media is framing this i
want you guys to understand that there
look it's not that the the government
will always use
their baton to gain power and they never
give it up joe rogan was talking about
this he was right you cut a lot of flack
for it you don't give up power to the
government the pandemic and get it back
no laws typically only grow the pages
get more plentiful they get longer font
gets smaller unless it's the green new
deal then they double space it size 12.
gotta make it five pages i'm gonna
stretch this someway somehow it's a pop
out
you had to get 500 words into nine pages
she was following that she's following
the uh the guidelines for her college
persuasive essay it reads like clifford
i like clifford i did like he's big and
he's red he's a dog he doesn't know he's
different it's like the first girl i was
with
big and red uh i don't know i don't know
what that means disgusting
i've never judged you more okay so curvy
yesterday the maxi the vaccine the
vaccine mandate for uh new york
healthcare workers went into effect now
before i get to what uh
unelected governor kathy uh kathy is it
kathy hochul it's sound i've only ever
read it i've never heard it pronounced
because no one voted for her and no one
likes her yeah nobody cares so it's just
like you know congratulations you're
you're an unelected queen uh did she get
in there is it was it just
they were like he grabbed her ass we
should let her be governor
i always wonder like if there's a scene
there's a serial sexual harasser yeah
like meryl streep you don't think she
turned a blind knight i don't have
harvey weinstein no we know she did we
know she did it's like this lady if she
was around governor cuomo who was
constantly harassing sexually harassing
women you think she didn't know about it
yeah of course they're looking to her
like you know right right so uh she
dresses in that pantsuit you know she's
it's like she's just using it as a
protection it's a sexual calling card
so uh she said that the unvaccinated
before we get to her call yesterday
about what she's going to do using the
military and her executive power
to
do something unprecedented in this
country uh
this is something that someone pulled
here in production uh which sort of
gives you an idea as to her mindset
uh from a while ago where she said that
the unvaccinated are not listening to
god unelected governor of new york we
are not through this pandemic i wished
we were
but i prayed a lot to god during this
time
and you know what god did answer our
prayers he made the smartest men and
women the scientists the doctors the
researchers he made them come up with a
vaccine that is from god to us and we
must say thank you god thank you and i
wear my vaccinated necklace all the time
to say i'm vaccinated
all of you
new relationships i know you're
vaccinated you're the smart ones but you
know there's people out there who aren't
listening to god and what god wants you
know this
black
minorities who don't trust the
government they're stupid and say we owe
this to each other
like a loop jesus taught us to love one
another
but to care about each other enough to
say please get vaccinated because i love
you i want you to live i want our kids
to be safe when they're in schools i
want you to be safe when you go to a
doctor's office or to a hospital i wear
look everybody look at this shows that
i'm vet you know what we should have one
of these for the unvaccinated or maybe
instead of these like a patch on the arm
like a triangle patch on the arm and you
know what maybe two triangles will put
in two triangles and maybe three
triangles so creates like a star
i see her vaccinated he went to jared
so let's be clear there's 72 000 workers
in new york who are unvaccinated okay
now let's be clear as to why there's a
shortage because this is going to
justify her executive action a lot of
hospitals we've talked about this they
were forced to pause elective procedures
you know like heart stints like hip
replacements yeah uh like heart valve
surgery mammograms because you know you
can't get those at planned parenthood
they've never actually done them despite
what they tried to tell you kidney stone
removal
just drink some dr pepper fine
so as a result that 1.4 million
healthcare workers were laid off right
laid off furloughed you know this your
wife is in their house yeah had their
hours cut there wasn't a staff shortage
because of covid let's be very clear you
go how was their staff shortage when
they didn't use that ship in new york
when they all well what happened is they
said hey we can't do any of these
elective procedures so uh it's just
going to be covered and we don't have
enough covid patients right now so we're
going to furlough you we are going to
lay you off just be re everyone needs to
understand that all references available
on the website so that sets this up
importantly because there are a lot of
healthcare workers up to one-third who
are unvaccinated and that should be
concerning
one-third of people who work in
healthcare the real heroes remember
refuse to get the vaccine and so there
will be an even worse shortage starting
midnight last night uh chronolog going
into effect that's what justifies
what the media is praising but what to
me is
look in all seriousness one of the
scariest moments in modern american
history
and we'll be nation leading with our
mandate which strikes at midnight
tonight when everyone is expected in a
hospital in the state of new york or a
health care facility to have been
vaccinated i will be signing an
executive order to give me the emergency
powers necessary to address the
shortages where they occur that's going
to allow me to
deploy the national guard who are
medically trained
deploy people uh who've been retired who
may have had a licensed lapse bring in
people from elsewhere that is not my
first position that my friends my bring
them in my desire is to have the people
who've been out there saying continue to
work in their jobs working them safely
and to all the other health care workers
who are vaccinated they also deserve to
know that the people they're working
with will not get them sick
okay uh let me be really clear about
something here because the media is
trying to paint this says hey
the unelected governor is uh sending in
help
yeah to prevent people from getting sick
no let's be really clear here this is a
governor abusing her executive power to
send in the united states
military because she needs to replace
nurses who would not comply being forced
to take a vaccine with no long-term
studies
that by the way hasn't stopped
breakthrough cases
let's be really clear that is terrifying
and it starts with it starts with things
like oh well you know it doesn't really
matter why do we want to fight about the
the mask thing why do you want if it's
only it's only companies that require
that have a hundred employees or more
that doesn't affect me sending in the
united states military because health
workers who by the way were heroes
apparently not unless they're twerking
on tick tock i don't know the rules i
just call them
yep a year ago
uh really quickly texas attorney do you
see this mark metzger
he was cited for disorderly conduct
after he was walking down galveston
beach dressed as michael myers
from halloween
and it was uh
[Music]
change the locks yeah yeah it's working
on it just it can't be
uh five five five five anymore in the
past
that's true yeah sorry about that yeah
no that really is my fault yeah it kind
of threw us off well we need to be a
little yeah through
like the michael's cut out i don't know
uh before he broke into my car and was
sleeping in it oh
how'd it smell though he's on the dip
smells really good
got to get him away from big chief all
right let's see uh speaking of big chief
let's see what's going on hey it's the
junk bond it's the junk muppet from
labyrinths
so
let's see what are they talking about uh
they're talking about the military
quarterback what were you pointing to in
cnn oh no i was disappointed
oh okay
i thought we were talking about their
song
no no new updates just uh
the junk monster
that freaked me out as a kid so that
movie was terrifying oh i i went to the
jim henson experience and i wrote my son
and like oh no
i was like this is still terrifying
still terrifying
yeah they're throwing their heads at me
it's the darkest movie they kidnap for
those who haven't seen labyrinth spoiler
alert in the first 10 minutes they
kidnap a baby from its own cradle yeah
and david bowie takes it for some reason
yeah david bowie takes it wearing the
most enormous cod piece you've ever seen
in your life
and then he's singing about kidnapping
no i kidnapped a baby
don't take your baby and throw them to
the stars jennifer connolly this is
spiders from babies
you remind me of the babe that i
kidnapped oh yeah yeah how about the
noise how about the biggest card please
you have yes
you sure this is big enough i don't
think my viewers will believe it
[Laughter]
chance can't be stance so
let's go to speaking of brits we'll go
to the less favorite john oliver yeah
and also he can't claim he banged mick
jagger
what wait what bowie bowie oh okay all
right bowie's come on it was i don't
know much about david bowie all right i
just choose not to put that crap in my
head
what excellent music no there's a dumb
sitting to my left
ground control to major hold on
which way is left he's sitting in that
chair
okay and he listens to the most peculiar
[ __ ]
i see i stand by my claim
all right well you're wrong you're wrong
because
well all right ziggy star suck
yeah
i mean i'll give it to you if you if you
have the dancing in the street video you
win but other than that they're very
good yeah okay
have you ever seen that silent no
there's a video on youtube where it's
david bowie and mick jagger just doing
the video with no music it's the
scariest thing on earth
terrifying
well labyrinth is terrifying because you
know when you're a kid right i don't
know about you but i was afraid like the
monsters under the bed you turn off the
light really quickly yeah and you run
and you jump on the bed because if
you're under the covers it's safe yeah
only this this troop this gaggle of
satanic muppets show up and steal you
from your bed it's your safe place when
you're a kid and then the junk muppet
lady is showing up in the closet yeah
trying to sell you trinkets that no
doubt are probably from china laced with
arsenic
it's a horrifying film they don't make
them like that and that's why kids are
pansies and we can't do gender reveals
because they don't have films like
labyrinth now everything is nerfed all
right that's true let's let's move on to
uh john oliver okay and i want to you
know what i think john let me be clear i
think john oliver compared to seth
meyers compared to stephen colbert
compared to trevor noah
samantha
uh is funny he is yeah i agree and you
guys can comment below if you i get that
he's smug i get that he's wrong credit
where it's due there are even some funny
bits in this video and i encourage you
to go watch the whole thing so you know
we're not taking it out of context uh
but this is a brit who's now crossed
over right he's on the other side of the
pond over here now because uh the only
way to be successful is not in
effectively the
semi-quasi-socialist hellhole that is
the uk especially the community have to
come to the united states but then he
wants to tell us how to run things here
and of course he comes to the united
states and wants to accuse us of being
racist
use and here's the thing with this one
i'm not super impressed uses the most
uh rudimentary arguments against voter
id laws to try and paint them as racist
so i want to go through this video
rebut each thing point well point out
sort of the the i guess intellectual
fallacies flaws that are used point by
point but before that i want to show you
some this is something you need to
understand
john oliver also it doesn't this is
where he tips his tips his hand here uh
when he talks about seat belt laws
he actually thinks that it's ridic
thinks it's ridiculous for a state to
not have a seat belt law let's just
watch this clip before we get to all the
id stuff all those states passed laws
that make it harder for people to vote
and if anyone is surprised to see new
hampshire up there let me just remind
you it's a state that's 88 white with a
republican governor and no adult seat
belt law sure they present themselves as
charming but deep down they are
basically just florida with foliage that
is it okay so let me be clear here about
something you know you had rage against
the machine we've pointed this out or
rock against bush right punk rock
against the system but of course they
were against bush but then they started
campaigning for obama is there anything
more machine than campaigning for a
president who believes in it but they
say no we're talking about the socialist
system but my body my choice right we're
still rebels is there anything less
rebellious than supporting the
government forcing you to wear a seat
belt my body my choice can you at least
admit that people who oppose for example
abortion up until birth that there can
be an argument even if you haven't
looked into the science of fetal
development that it affects someone else
it is another life it is another uh dna
sequence another heartbeat that is
autonomous from you a seat belt law
affects no one else i want to be clear
you're an idiot if you don't wear a belt
if you don't wear a seat belt i've never
ridden my motorcycle without a helmet
helmet laws are stupid that is not the
role of government john oliver comedy is
meant to rebel against the king right
the court jester he is saying
government is daddy government is your
big brother
can you imagine lenny bruce getting up
there smoking and smoking a cigarette
can you believe that there's no seatbelt
laws
they're just giving awards after
his punchline actually sounded kind of
fun it's like florida with foliage i'm
like well that sounds quite nice that
does sound quite nice but just think
about it for a second can we all agree
if we're going to say my body my choice
yeah
seat belt laws should be the first to go
and you know why that exists do you know
why seat belt sleep out lows it's like
florida with foliage do you know why it
exists to make the cops more money so
they can pull you over do you realize
that in certain pr in certain precincts
across this country you are better off
pulling over 10 people for a seat belt
infraction than a rapist because you
have more civilian interactions and you
generate more revenue really remember
the police that you say are racist and
you hate hey hey we need a reason to
pull over black people not saying the
police are racist you said that uh-oh
seat belt
i was wearing my seatbelt officer not
according to me can't prove it yeah i
couldn't see it
he reached for his buckle yeah reach for
his buckles come on it's a it's a
terrible it's a 67
i don't know
cars
you say there's no seat belt i know
nothing about cars they have seat belts
i don't know what cars are they from the
mustang and that's just because i saw
bullet yes well there was the mint green
i can't remember what it was and uh my
cousin vince oh of course
the point is the corvette you are a
quizling you're a patsy for the
higher-ups john oliver and this sets the
tone because it's not about the vaccine
right they say well you're you're
unvaccinated it could affect me okay so
that's your line right the reason you
only support the vaccine man is because
it connect because my actions could
negatively affect you it's not my body
my choice right even though you have the
vaccine you don't trust it 80 of people
in wales for example you know not too
far from your uh your home stomping
grounds are vaccinated but you're saying
my decision affects you okay how about
seat belt laws
how does that affect you
the point is there is no line
no okay so now we'll move on here to one
other intellectual fallacy which just
shows you how disingenuous john oliver
is where he talks about donald trump uh
to set this up right because it's look
at this people seat belt laws it is
donald trump warmonger racist right
although one of those things really
doesn't fit see if he can catch it some
of the biggest efforts to undermine
voting rights have been concentrated in
the closest states in last year's
election especially these three where
biden's combined margin of victory was
less than 43 000 votes if they had gone
the other way trump would still be
president right now meaning kovid would
be even worse we'd be at war with i
don't know let's say luxembourg and we'd
all be living under attorney general my
pillow guy i know things are bleak right
now but depressingly it's also important
to remember
this is technically the better timeline
okay uh donald trump is the only
president who hasn't started a new war
since jimmy carter just to be clear
signed four peace deals in the middle
east which was unprecedented you know
contrasted with uh joe biden who uh you
know bombed 10 civilians including seven
children light about it so i'm just
saying tomato
tomato potate i'm also a little unsure
how kovid would respond to his
presidency yeah i didn't know kova would
be like oh that guy's in office let's go
in and be more effective why don't we
love vaccines yeah he had the trump
vaccine he brought the he brought in the
vaccine yeah he makes the claim and the
audience just accepts it covid would be
worse underdogs
luxembourg and covert would be even more
overponzemic really
really luxembourg have an army no
luxembourg is basically a tax haven i
don't know luxembourg is the only place
in the world with a higher average
income in the united states
well then we should invade and take
their money yeah of course why are we
just showing up to their banks them in
the cayman islands just swat a few
crocodiles on the way get out of here
you got your banks it's mine don't even
take that long do they even have guns
there i don't know
the swiss banks the point is by two
o'clock today the united states should
own the cayman islands the swiss banks
luxembourg and luxembourg okay
now we'll get to the meat of this
argument that voter id laws and this is
the whole segment uh are racist
because well you know what let's just
let john oliver uh the enlightened ones
tell us yeah all these states have put
harsher voter id requirements in place
even though federal court cases found
black and latino voters in states with
harsh laws disproportionately lacked
access to the types of voter ids
required to vote so already when you do
read these bills you quickly find some
[ __ ] in plain view
uh
i do find some of it in plain view
i don't even think his black fan is
buying this
it used to be blue until the junk bond
lady reminded me i heard a black one
came out of me closet so
let's go through this before he's it's
wrong he says they disproportionately
don't have id let's go through the
definition of racism first to be clear a
belief that a ra that race is a
fundamental determinant of human traits
and capacities and that racial
differences produce an inherent
superiority of a particular race okay i
don't know that saying hey
flash your id so we know you're here
legally qualified
the same rule should apply to white
americans black americans brown
americans
any
any color yeah and i love how he says
the the the required form of oh you mean
a driver's license you mean the thing
that you have to have to check out a
book or drive a car i don't know get on
an airplane and it's not even a vp card
or a passport yeah there's a lot of
options here uh which are provided by
the government which i'll get to in a
second so well and north dakota was
highlighted like oh yeah all the black
people there in north dakota
they're really couple yeah when i think
of north dakota i think black people and
when i think of black people in north
dakota i think they're really getting
skunked and being requested to present
identification that sucks it's just i
mean i'm just looking for the hoods i'm
going to guess that they all have id 87
of black people's house
87 of black people 90 of uh latin
americans have some form of confirmed
photo id in georgia which i believe he
brought up did he bring that up there
georgia i don't know 97 of registered
voters in georgia have a valid id voter
id laws increased turnout though in
georgia that's the interesting thing it
increased turnout from 2004 to 2008.
140 percent increase among hispanic and
latino voters voters a 42 increase since
voter id laws among black voters
compared to only 8 percent of whites
let's be clear because what they're
trying to do is compare it again say oh
well in the pandemic so many more people
came out and voted by mail yeah that's
not how you should vote it's rife with
flaws it was meant to be temporary
during a pandemic yeah
see a pattern here temporary right
temporary during a pandemic we just need
to make sure that we can force these
vaccines during a pendulum we just need
to make sure that we can release that
well we can just release the national
guard here basically declare martial
under a pandemic oh we just need to make
sure that we change the entire voter
system during the pandemic
and now they want that to be the
standard moving forward before the
pandemic the voter id laws
disproportionately benefited voters of
color well that means it's racist yes
against white people only eight percent
yeah
why do you deserve it
by the way the majority of black
americans say that you should be forced
to present id to vote oh
whitey on the moon yeah
let's keep in mind too also 72 percent
of black
are
peop
so are our vaccine mandates racist i
just want to know i just want to
understand the rules
right governor of new york who's not
elected
and business you're the smart ones the
stupid ones oh hold on a second do you
mean in your state you're the largest
city in your state you mean that 72
percent of black people are dumb because
they don't trust you
a woman who looks like a white
caricature from german folklore tales
yeah and you're refusing service to
those people in restaurants and bars and
it's the new white wait so so you're
just basically backdooring keeping black
people out of establishments yeah voter
id disproportionately up until 2008 all
references available disproportionately
in the states they were implemented
increased black and brown voter turnout
just to be clear you have implemented
vaccine mandates vaccine passports that
disproportionately affect black people
72 percent of black people you're the
racist also bonus what you're doing is
unconstitutional hey
next clip
none of this is anything new republicans
have been pushing restrictive voting
laws for years back in 2013 north
carolina crafted a law that made it so
the only acceptable forms of voter id
were the ones disproportionately used by
white people a federal appeals court
later said targeted african-american
voters with almost surgical precision
which has to be the second worst context
in which to hear that phrase topped only
by surgery okay that's funny yeah uh but
it's also very wrong
so let's be the states we're talking
about i think it's uh is it six states
yeah six six states with the strictest
id voter laws okay
they accept or they issue a form of free
voter identification please tell me i
don't understand how is that white how
is it how is free first off how is the
driver's license white and by the way
the reason that they would say it's
always because disproportionately in
places like new york city where people
are a lot of people of color are
unvaccinated they often use public
transit yeah however
across the country where they don't live
in huge cities
black people
a driver's license isn't very well i
would even argue it's not even very
white to ask for a driver's license in
harlem i bought
i bought 32 ounces because i couldn't
find a 40 one time in harlem i went to
dinosaur barbecue guess what they asked
for my id
and i was surrounded by black people
yeah you have to be you have to have a
license to be able to drink they looked
angry with me yeah
shouldn't wear flip-flops that was well
white people what do you do you get a
white license yeah oh that i don't know
if you guys forget that well it's our
white privilege card too so a driver's
license is racist and so is
free id that anyone can get from the
government the point here is not to
burden people with costs it's silly if
you know what it costs to get id it's a
non-argument there's also free id from
the government it is very clear the
intent here just to make sure that like
you said we're saying the same thing
here talking about the margin of error
you talked about arizona wisconsin right
42 000 i think votes he said
and we're saying the exact same thing
we're going yeah absolutely and you have
voted you don't have voting requirements
that are strict enough to make sure that
illegals don't illegal immigrants don't
vote that steals the vote away from a
legal citizen including by the way a
black american citizen that's where the
majority of black americans support
voter i.d laws let's be clear about this
let's go on to the next clip where now
he makes the argument that because of
uneven distribution this is the old
right this is the old not equality
equity argument right means that it's uh
some kind of discrimination brnovich
versus dnc essentially found that even
if a voting restriction has a
discriminatory impact that in itself
doesn't necessarily violate the voting
rights act those two decisions basically
made it easier for some states to pass
discriminatory laws while at the same
time making it much harder for anyone to
challenge them okay is anyone buying
this [ __ ] can you just comment below is
this is anyone buying this is this
convincing like i i will watch oh that's
a pretty good argument you can hear it
from someone yeah someone like noam
chomsky right sometimes sometimes even
someone like a rachel maddow i'll watch
like okay how would i know you can say
not theirs
these decisions and therefore there are
some more black people who don't have
votes uh court case which i don't
understand uh
yeah yep so that was nice of him the
first court case was saying that you
didn't have to run your laws by the
federal government that was the one he
didn't cover in the clip that we showed
there he covered it which by the way
democrats actively support because they
don't want some kind of federal statute
when it comes to voting laws let's be
really clear because that's what it is
by some conservatives which i opposed
yeah but he didn't even he didn't even
get into that and then the comment that
he makes is like even if it has a
disproportionate effect okay john oliver
the only thing you're focusing on is
expanding the number of people voting
which is not all bad but here's the
problem you want to make sure it's
secure first yes that's what you have to
do first i want people to vote i just
don't want people who aren't uh american
people to vote you know like russians
like you said
teams or canadians yeah for four years
anyone should vote
yes it's a human right no people
are illegal wait we're talking about
voting sorio forgot my catchphrase
so
some people are illegal it's trevor
noah's whole thing yes yes this is by
the way again going back to the vast
majority of black americans support some
kind of voter id law okay so they
disagree with you this is another
example of a white purse of a white
person a very white person saying that
they speak for black people you don't
speak for black people listen black
people don't want voter id there's just
some kind of shotgun hey
shut the [ __ ] up hey they don't want to
they think it's racist i'm a
no i'm just so turtle red costume
seriously they don't they don't agree
with you they don't but he speaks for
them stephen so they have to otherwise
they ain't black can i say this anyone
here know about the tension between the
black community and latino americans do
people know about that that they're not
that black americans aren't really
thrilled with illegal immigration for
them again if this is a big reason that
record numbers of black people voted for
donald trump because it affects them
directly as it results to employment
so you're probably not speaking for the
mr liverpool all right here's another
one we talked about how republicans are
fearmongering yes because we haven't
seen that
through this clip uh and pushing voter
id laws i will say despite the fact
state and local officials found the last
election to be the most secure in
american history
just say it many republicans don't trust
the system but the reason for that might
be that people like dan patrick spent
all of last year calling voting by mail
a scam by democrats to steal the
election and saying [ __ ] like this
look when you have an opportunity to
steal a vote the democrats will take
advantage of it you can swing the
balance easily ed i could give you 10
scenarios but i won't because i don't
want to give anyone ideas how you could
easily steal thousands of votes
oh come on
i i damn i don't really care what dan pacquiao i
don't even know how it was dan patrick
or danica patrick well
something about cars with her right yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know not a lot of
winning but a lot of driving she drives
did she drive a scarlot she was good
though yes okay buick i'm in the loop so
with positive attraction
so he says it's the most secure in
american history well we can just say i
can say things too for example like i
can say you speak for black people
doesn't mean it's right and let's be
clear that was not what many democrats
were saying right who amy klobuchar
elizabeth warren jimmy carter they all
warned about the fact that it was one of
the greatest national security threats
to our election and even nor mcdonald we
talked about this remember he got it he
nailed it he was on a show and he said
uh we ran the clip i think you can find
it on craigslist of course you know when
uh donald trump uh talked about
democrats rigging the election in 2016
they said there was none that could
happen but
of course you're saying the exact
opposite now exactly yeah really was the
most secured american history but to so
for some reason we you we believe the
left who are saying 2016 was rigged
russians uh ten thousand dollars in
facebook ads okay we get it and then
they say when we take that exa the exact
same parameters that we had in 2016
increase them to unprecedented voting by
mail however yeah well we've smoothed
over the wrinkles
by the way you know what that you're
inferring that every other election
previously held had some degree of
insecurity to it well more so than this
one even of course they always say that
about elections that they don't remember
george bush with florida yeah people
don't realize this about florida no no
al gore wanted to count three counties
in florida in the recount george we're
saying how about you count the whole
state he's like no no no let's just
count three counts of three go back to
your swedish masseuse al and your seat
at apple the point is they always
complain about elections they don't win
case in point hillary clinton i think
this is in 2018 yes talking about the
election before the most secure in
history some tax experts in
silicon valley valley with whom i have
met who say that you know maybe what
they'll do this next time is to really
disrupt the actual election
shut down the servers that you send
results to
uh interfere with the operation
machines because still
too many of them are linked to the
internet
so they're we are still very vulnerable
yeah we'll go right back to that because
that is actually here's the thing first
you're like oh hilary stab her with a
diazepam pen
like the guy at 310 to yuma gonna hang
me in the morning the point is stops the
seizures um then she was right
it turned out there were machines hooked
up to the internet no
oh what i was told that's not possible
it's not possible i know because you're
listening to the brit what what
you don't listen to he's the most secure
most secure election in history 81
million votes there's no discrepancy no
and
breakthrough cases are rare dave ah i
understand that it's a pandemic pandemic
the breakthrough cases but very rare
unvaccinated both things are true
uh real quick what check that out so
this is kind of big news right now this
actually goes against exactly what joe
biden was saying about leaving troops it
says that his generals were telling him
to actually leave some troops behind oh
really yeah john goodman's gonna play
him in the movie well he's gonna have to
drop a few and also paint his face gray
you're gonna have to use like a charcoal
lens filter no goodman's uh he's lost
some weight oh has he yeah i guess when
you sell out the star of the show that
broke you
uh you dropped it it makes sense
i think that's his soul leaving his body
i think that's going to be kind of a big
deal as we yeah let's go back to it uh
now let's go back to the john oliver we
have to kind of clip along sure uh
republic no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no i want to come
in more of this
just riveting
i want to pour more bleach in my eyes
stay awake
i'm awake republican no i it's tough for
all of us here but this is we need look
and i want you to have all the
references available yeah in the link
below link below you also have the
tickets to dave's uh dave's show on on
october 1st uh here he makes the next
claim that uh republicans use baseless
claims of voter fraud and of course
that's not true one of them involves the
uh computers being hooked up uh the
system is being hooked up to the
internet is hillary clinton specified
but you know let's let john oliver make
his argument okay and local election
supervisors themselves will tell you
that these bills make no sense the
florida supervisors of elections
strongly opposed their state's new bill
with one republican supervisor telling a
reporter it's stupid okay it was a
solution looking for a problem but it's
actually one step worse than that
because these are solutions to problems
that have been deliberately and
strategically manufactured
it's pretty obvious here use [ __ ]
claims to stir up baseless fear to pass
unnecessary restrictions targeting
particular groups yeah because you can't
stand unnecessary restrictions mr seat
belt law
unbelievable that's like saying hey
don't put the plexiglas up that's
bulletproof in the bank this bank has
never been robbed before what do you
just this is a problem that doesn't
exist honey don't carry a gun because
you've never been raped before don't
install a security system in your house
because we've never had anybody break
into this house before it's not like
these things haven't happened in history
so john oliver's saying this is a
problem or a solution looking for a
problem you're wrong yeah it isn't you
protect against problems that you know
are possible okay that's a very good
point only one fatal flaw in your
argument a little angry all those things
actually happened uh yeah the bank was
robbed the woman was raped in the house
got broken into georgia their secretary
of state brad ratzenberger our favorite
he said that some 1 000 residents voted
twice in the state's 2020 june primary
oh my god so let's be clear these are
things before the election yeah i want
to i'm giving you some examples before
this election because we're not allowed
to talk about this election safe and
most secure history right we all agree
absolutely happened in new jersey as
well in 2020 a judge ruled and ordered a
new election after a city councilman was
charged with what did what what fraud
charged with fraud 2019 a new election
was held in north carolina's ninth
district due to abnormalities in the
absentee vote totals and allegations of
ballot harvesting never happens
i'm not i'm not talking about anything
in the most uh most secure election in
history yeah we'll get to the arizona
audit in a second come at me bro these
are all things that happened clark
county nevada a local election of just
153 000 votes was thrown out due to a
large number of um discrepancies 153 000
votes well i think that's what the k
means after 150 those are good
what was the discrepancy trump was
elected on it yeah
this isn't going to work
it's an error oh
this one ah trash
in california during the primary right
during the primary of the election more
than 100 000 mail-in ballots were
rejected what didn't happen in the
general election no
is that even possible i think it was 27
000 rejected because the signatures
didn't even match the voter or there was
no signature at all well let's let's go
to our other favorite state in new york
oh yes after june 2020 election two
congressional seats still had not been
decided these guys are efficient and
good plus over 250 000 voters in new
york could be illegal or using false
social security numbers okay well let's
be careful with that because now we're
talking we're going through all the
problems that could lead up to the most
safe and secure elections right right we
want to talk about they fixed it all but
at least 50 000 of those illegals live
next door to me in harlem yes
i mean one apartment and sold you
sombreros for taco tuesday until john
oliver said that's offensive yep they
did it was a nacho sombrero well then
where do you put the tacos
oh you're wearing a pawn show
that's cultural appropriation who do you
think sold it to me you limey
so is you'd pretending to be american
every time i've purchased a sombrero and
i purchased quite a few i've done it
we all have buy
well i see him in you know in texas
wearing sun sombrero hats when they're
working outside that's from the sky mall
catalog that is yeah from the jay
peterman
it's
the very sombrero he had tried on yes
elaine i find myself in the rainy street
all right
these are the stories elaine sombreros
as i fall under the spell of opium
now he goes on to say that the arizona
audit and this is something that's
they're banking on you not looking at
the audit and i want to be very clear
the only thing that i will talk about in
this audit are things that can be found
in the report information publicly
available
i guess it didn't show up at slate and
salon which are sources that john oliver
uses unironically
but he goes on to just claim that the
arizona audit
showed no issue just look what happened
this week the nonsense audit in arizona
came to a humiliating conclusion that
failed to show yet again that trump was
cheated on victory but its organizers
still recommended the legislature
tighten up the election process to
provide additional certainty going
forward because of course they [ __ ]
did it's all a shameless attempt to get
to the same place okay so let's be clear
the leftist media is saying that the
recount and by the way i i know that
people oh we can't talk about this no we
we should be able to talk about the
report it was on the news and the left
doesn't want you to read the report just
like one one third
one third of whale's coveted patients
are unvaccinated
wait what happened to the two-thirds
don't do the white eater don't think
about it they made a recommendation but
they couldn't officially change the vote
that's no however
right
it didn't match the 2020 numbers let's
be really clear 57 000 ballots had
potential issues wow so let's go through
some of this to be really clear if you
were more than uh donald trump lost by
significantly more than the margin
significantly more than the margin of
error but again a big reason is they
can't we can't confirm exactly what
these discrepancies are because why well
think about democrats sued to stop the
audit so that was a little bit of a
roadblock right absolutely weird what
would you do the maricopa county uh
election board and dominion refuse
subpoenas oh so for things like
envelopes with signatures for mail and
ballots routers passwords login
information let me ask you this could
you refuse a subpoena
you've done some time could you refuse a
subpoena some people oh so subpoena yeah
we're still we're off
i'm sorry i heard it differently uh no
and no no no but they don't play by the
rules
i didn't know i could do it when
dominion did that i thought well i don't
know you can do that it's like all right
subpoena you have to give this
information you have to go what like
well routers passwords logins to make
sure that none of these machines were
connected to the internet right hillary
clinton talked about and the menu just
goes no
you can do that okay no no they can do
that
so
239 000 ballot images were corrupted
files entered after november 1st 2020.
this is in the report
so half of the images after november
november 1st are corrupted that's insane
21 273 scanned ballot images are missing
wait a minute just missing
hey dominion can you tell us why these
are missing
no we dropped them off in detroit
that's a real red wagon
so what is it you can't confirm the
so what happens is they say look you
have these discrepancies but you can't
confirm the totals in the voting
machines you can't confirm this confirm
the scam images you can't confirm the
physical paper ballots this is there's
no way to make that argument
that's incredible it means you can never
actually fully audit an election to come
to any kind of it's a understanding if
anything happened and machines have been
there's this uh what was it called uh
kill kill chain yeah on hbo to be really
clear
there's a there's a before the 2020
election it was kill chain and this guy
talked about how elections could be
easily hacked oh yeah how insecure they
are he didn't know what he was making
because now he's a liberal but uh he
actually hacked the georgia voting
machines in real time you can watch him
do it he went to like this this whatever
nerdcon thing where these computer
hackers hack it and say oh yeah it's
really easy i just switched these vote
totals yeah how the machines are
connected to the internet intermittently
and he proved that and
that was that that's something of course
happened this election well they're
never connected to the internet well yes
they are so this is something that's
relevant we're not saying that you're
going to find 57 000 votes that all read
you know uh uh hillary clinton we're
just saying
there's no way to know when you refuse
subpoenas there's no way to know when
files are corrupted there's no way to
know when you have these discrepancies
and they just say well we're not going
to give you the info no logins no router
info passwords handing over computers
nothing and you know what he also did go
and watch this documentary it's
fascinating he took a card he hacked a
card what the kill chain yeah kill champ
put the card in the machine and then
said hey go vote and tell me what you
voted he flipped all of the votes by
having that card entered first right he
literally was able to do that live on
camera to a voting board to show them
how much they had a problem it was the
swedish guy was he swedish or it was
norwegian something like that something
like that or one of those one of those
countries nordic and he was the
elections are not safe they're very easy
to hack and look at georgia and uh look
i hacked a selection and it was
connected to the internet in this car
and they're like oh 20 20 uh uh what
happened
or whatever it's safe you know
and then hbo it's like they couldn't
they couldn't be faster in removing it
from suggesting i know i'm sure he was
like the top three documentaries for a
long time and it's like whoop nope do
you want to watch girls
no no no seth meyers i'd rather watch
david bowie's copy oh
lena dunham how does so much pretty get
in one person well she just made one man
very lucky got married oh did she really
let's just please oh she's off the
market
really
yes she's unavailable i know
well all right there goes my plan yes
foiled yet again planned a lawyer around
talbots yeah walk outside and say put
put your clothes on
[Laughter]
ruining swimming for everyone
my kid just threw up lately yeah okay
listen let's just let's we'll get back
to the buoyancy issues
talented yeah talent beautiful and brave
capital t here's his next
point we have to end the filibuster what
is this what does it have to do with all
right let's hear his argument mitch
mcconnell has announced that he will
filibuster any attempt to get either of
those acts passed so
if we want to protect the ballot which
we absolutely should we need to end the
philippines you just say he wants to
protect the ballot that every national
democratic politician don't want people
to have identification about this but
some are doing the exact opposite
okay they just want to do away with the
filibuster to ram through any
unconstitutional you know the kind of
crap that goes through in your country
the kind of crap that goes through in
australia historically democrats have
loved the filibuster they use the
filibuster longer than anyone in history
why why why to continually oppose the
civil rights act that was oh no it was
pushed and voted on by republicans 60
days 60-day filibustering
robert
you had robert byrd who was fourth in
line for the presidency and used the
n-word on live television three times in
a row in 2004
oh boy guy had clan dental in a company
car and then there's trom thurman who
people say look oh this is the big
switch so democrat at the time strom
thurman heals the record for longest
filibuster in history i believe the
second is robert byrd both against the
civil rights act okay it was for 24
hours and 18 minutes wow
that's a long stamp and then then you
have yeah robert byrd here 14 hours geez
14 hours they really didn't want black
people to vote
he went a day without taking a seat
without using the restroom and without
eating food or drinking water yeah and
make sure black people couldn't vote yes
and to be clear what people this is
something too that people often use they
go well actually the party switched
really because robert braziled them i
got like oh there are a lot of examples
okay name me one you're gonna say strong
thurman i bet you're going to say strong
thurman they go oh strom thurman this is
something they don't tell you strom
thurman became a republican when he
developed a relationship with god and
realized that he was wrong about his
racist ways and he was actually the
first senator in the south to actually
hire black aids put people into a
senatorial equivalent of a cabinet well
that's good so when you look at it
voting against civil rights act as a
democrat very racist as a democrat then
there's the flash of genius moment the
conversion republican starts hiring a
black people i'm sure his pet names for
them weren't the nicest but baby steps
that's true and he didn't like them near
his pool
as a democrat as a democrat
we need to be clear because people just
go oh he switched what's the only one
they can point to yeah
he became a better person when he
switched that's the whole point ebenezer
scrooge felt as light as a feather mary
is a schoolboy the ending matters okay
um
then you have in 2010 bernie sanders he
filibustered a bipartisan tax cut deal
for eight and a half hours well he hates
it if you get to spend your own money
they just look they want to make they
want you all to think that there's fraud
where there is no fraud and they want
you to believe that the filibuster is
some kind of republican game of mind
control just like the hippie believed
this the hippies who believe the same
thing about deodorant when the fact is
they're the ones who use it the most
they they used it for the most uh amount
of time the longest amounts of time yeah
and you want the filibuster to stay
around you do not want things going
through on a 51-49 vote that are this
consequential okay you want it both ways
republicans you don't want to get rid of
it even when we were in power now we
haven't been talking about getting rid
of it at all right you want that there
to make sure you don't get run rough
shot over because everybody votes party
line now it sucks okay i don't say to
get rid of it i don't think hippies use
soap
no they don't it's a government form of
mind control bro
sophists use the crystal deodorant the
crystal stick deodorant yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay ultraman gotta wet
it before all right
hippies
can't stand them long hair they're in
power now no one liked hippies by the
way the 70s the 60s were not nearly as
filthy as people believe when they look
back just the media had a
a love a romantic infatuation with
hippies most americans were tired of
them thought they were filthy disgusting
i wanted to go back to class oh it was
haydashberry and woodstock that was your
hippies yeah those were your hippies and
by the way most people were like oh
they're screwing in the mud who were the
golden years no look most americans
were being productive yeah you were
screwing in the mud in a field and you
didn't even bring food
to have us bring it in for you smart
mushrooms of course our our generation
of woodstock 99 was like hey let's set
this on fire yeah let's destroy
everything it's really not all that
different just breaking laws there were
a lot of rape at the original woodstock
that people didn't want to talk about
me too sexual liberation what do you
think happens when you're all naked in
the mud and on drugs
now you're surrounded by uh you're
surrounded by gentlemen the best concert
ever that's what happened stephen yeah
the best concert ever i just told my
young music stuff
here's another where he uses john oliver
uh 2018 what uh commission on civil
rights i don't know let's see what this
next clip is it's not convincing if you
do actually read these bills you quickly
find that you first absolutely make it
harder to vote and particularly for
certain people so tonight we thought we
would take a look at the attack on
voting rights and how best to fight it
and let's start with what is in these
bills because it's a lot for instance in
texas where remember that you claimed
you can't find a single instance of
voter suppression one thing that bill
does is roll back a lot of the
innovative measures put in place during
the pandemic that made voting more
accessible among other things it gets
rid of 24-hour and drive-through voting
both methods that harris county
implemented last year as the county
clerk who oversaw that election points
out when you look at the precincts where
those methods were most popular it's
clear that the harm is pretty targeted
why are we taking 24-hour voting away
because 56 percent of voters in november
who use 24-hour voting were people of
color and they know that why are we
taking drive-through voting away because
53
of those behalf in 2020 were people of
color
yeah it's pretty obvious who is being
targeted there okay let's be really
clear here not only is a matter of half
and they'll say but as a percentage of
the population keep in mind they say
people of color so they're talking about
all people of color right in this report
i believe it includes blacks uh uh latin
americans and i believe asians as well
why drive by voting is also right yes
exactly
i read it wrong so
michael douglas shows up take some
shooting lessons that's all so
here's something that's important here
if it's 50 you said 52 i believe 53 53
okay we're people of color here's the
thing it doesn't matter it's half
doesn't matter it's not half it comes
down to what's right now look if that 47
percent who are not people of color let
me ask this are there votes in any way
the people who did not do drive through
voting the people who registered the
people who went through the process
right the most secure process that we
have which of course is not mail and
voting
is there any world in which their votes
negatively impact the 53 the legitimacy
of the votes i'm not talking about who
they vote for even though you don't like
it i'm saying is there any way that
those votes steal those no okay when
we're talking about melon voting when
we're talking about node voter id is
there any way in which that 53 percent
of voters of color could negatively
impact could take away the legitimate
votes of the 47 yes hey wait a second mr
seatbelt law we're now talking about
protecting the rights of individuals to
not be infringed upon by someone else
including the sanctity of the vote just
ensuring that it is legal that it is
fair let's also be clear about this the
report that he's referencing in this
video suggests that convicted felons are
votes that need to be counted and that
felony disenfranchisement is evidence of
racism the presumption dares that uh
most felons are black people now we can
talk about statistical realities but the
problem is you will say that it's racist
until you're trying to vote harvest
exactly right and you don't have the
right not to get out of your car to vote
you also think about 24-hour voting you
have to staff that right so that's
expensive to have people there and then
poll watchers who typically you know
sleep and have jobs to go to aren't you
board up the voting precinct and kick
them out well that's true so they don't
they don't watch the vote at all right
oh my god
look here is my point there's no
suggestion that is made by john oliver
to ensure the legitimacy of the vote
yeah no he just says this is racist
that's racist disenfranchising okay look
how do you make sure you're just saying
it's the safest and most secure
how do you make sure that americans who
vote
know that their vote is counted
legitimately and that it's not cancelled
out by someone here illegally how do you
know
that's the case how do you ensure that's
the case with no voter id how do you
ensure that's the case with no voter id
because it's racist even though vast
majority of black americans disagree
with you white savior and they all have
voter id by a significant majority i
think was 87 i just talked about 90 of
people of color in general how do you
ensure that the black people's votes in
the united states who want voter id who
want to make sure that their votes count
by the way who came out in higher
numbers for donald trump because they're
more enthusiastic they're taking more of
an uh more of an active role in the
election process right now
how do you ensure that they trust the
vote you're just you're just talking
about ways you're just suggesting ways
to make sure that they don't so allow me
to offer a suggestion here and everyone
out there it's really simple how do you
ensure the legitimacy of the vote
voter id that's the fastest way voter id
and outside of a pandemic which is what
we were told the only we were told it
was the only reason that that's why we
are doing this mail-in voting and
drive-through voting if you can't trust
drive-through to get your filet of fish
right maybe electing the leader of the
free world should go another direction
the easiest way is starting with voter
id and how do you make this case look at
the references make it very clear to
people the majority of people of color
illness in this country support it the
majority of i guess white is a shade
supported and the majority of all
americans here who are here legally
supported and believe that it is the
first step to ensure there is no
disenfranchisement of the vote period
john oliver doesn't want you to know it
he offers no solutions just you know
what hey unlike john oliver you want to
confirm this we have the references
go talk to a black guy
there's an 87 percent chance that he'll
say
no idea vote you were taught it because
they don't they don't play pc right they
say use those words i would never use
those words i'm just saying i can't
judge the culture that may use words
that you find offensive it's not for me
to say that it's offensive because i'm
not a white savior like john oliver okay
youtube thank you very much you have to
go we're gonna test some popcorn
[Music]